how's it going res but I feel that
welcome back to a slender game made by
marks engine brave purchase I don't know
what's going on but they did a new
little update on it even though I played
it yesterday sanatorium I don't like
this let's prepare for jump scares
collect all five pages all right I can
do that
I can totally do that there's one in
here I know I missed a note that was in
here everyone come about it no escape oh
[ __ ] me that is scares me every time so
much but seriously though I mean it's
easily to gets tracted by hundred
percent more suds that is pretty
impressive vamoose oops
muchachos he can't come already it's
only been one note right
Thunder oh [ __ ]
No let's go in here let's go in here oh
you can run I guess
dude don't worry breast I got this
so no no profession oh it got lighter it
came from the forest so the notes are at
the same spot this time at least which
is it makes it a lot easier to finish so
I might actually do this
don't worry breasts are you scared
well [ __ ] me there's a lion over there
oh there we go
took my girl now coming for me [ __ ] me
[ __ ] me
Wow crazy
Diane save me I don't like this lion Wow
gosh such a pathetic lion where the [ __ ]
is he isn't this where we started no me
gusta Wow
oh don't worry rest I got this
don't worry it's not a problem
everything is some kind I mean I got
lion on my side alright let's just get
what we want in here and get out there's
nothing
oh it bothers me so much that I hope we
haven't seen him yet it just kills me
oh I scream I'll thank heavens thank you
ice cream this is why he's chasing me
isn't it he want my [ __ ] bargain bar
- ice cream for fruits no shava dude
don't come to me don't do it oh wait ah
Darius its camping by the ice cream
[ __ ] ice cramper always watching [ __ ]
you for only only for god dammit I
thought I had at least five well you
live in your life that's okay I'm a
professional okay let's keep going
breasts we're doing super good super gay
ah there we go
five notes [ __ ] huh decide Adam no no
no no I just want to stay here
I don't want to go out there again how
[Music]
okay let's run here run pits don't worry
don't look back don't look back don't
look back don't look back don't look
back don't look back don't look back yes
don't look back don't look back don't
look back oh okay
no problemas I think we chased them away
good thing I'm a professional [ __ ] I'm
lost
what is the [ __ ] yes lion no one
survives we'll see about that
six pages [ __ ] six [ __ ] pages
[ __ ] at six [ __ ] pages I can do this
there's a chance for me shovel look what
what what are you doing
let's go in here I got this let's go
over here I don't know what these are
what are you doing in there ah shut get
running pooch ah don't worry Sava no
Beckett oh [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ]
me [ __ ] me so [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] me [ __ ]
me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] [ __ ]
bhag bhag keep running keep rank lion
[Music]
are you [ __ ] kidding me
okay Diane oh yeah
there's something where's the last note
lion
you're gonna die PET SHOP lion you don't
know me
one more notch bit just one more [ __ ]
note don't worry don't worry don't worry
don't worry don't worry what is it I
should just cut it okay don't worry bad
don't worry I got you girl
I got deals I got ears like a deals like
a deal because they're doing deals like
a deal looking good why the [ __ ] is in
doubt whereas that I can't take it
anymore
best be joking right now
oh you [ __ ]
we're actually fine we're not fine
[Music]
Shabbat Sabbath them oh you don't know
it can add damn I was so close so close
salmonella
nope we're gonna gonna that was good one
next one for shizzle on my schnitzel
pretzel pizza l-- Fritzl yeah let's just
go with it in their web browser I have
faith in you
good
[Music]
oh yeah you like that buy you like that
British and whadda what right seems good
Thank You sugar
I asked you'd better believe I'm good at
it
[Applause]
[Music]